over the last two weeks I have had the
very very meaningful experience of
having the opportunity to read the
spiral staircase my climb out of
darkness and just to show you how on the
front wave of things we are this book
was given to me as a pre publication
date because the book was only published
this past Tuesday so we are here in this
very lovely occasion to inaugurate this
book with Karen Armstrong and the knot
company and so it's a very special
privilege for us most of you I know over
the past decade have read several of
Karen Armstrong studies on Islam Judaism
and Christianity in which she is seeking
to enlighten us on a multi-faith
dialogue and perspective and
demonstrating that we are all seeking
the same God we have these books in the
other room and you'll have the
opportunity to purchase them and to
purchase the spiral staircase which
Karen will autograph for you afterwards
the history of God biographies of
Muhammad and Buddha Jerusalem one city
and three faiths I'm not going on
because she has now written 15 books and
you'll have a chance to browse onto my
thing tonight she's going to share with
us a more personal spiritual journey
which interweaves her own story with the
story of her interfaith journey that she
has made and I want to read to you from
the final paragraph of this wonderful
new book of hers she says I picture a
narrow spiral staircase I tried to get
off of it and join others on what seemed
to me to be a broad noble flight of
steps thronged with people but I kept
falling off
and when I went back to my own twisting
stairwell
I found a fulfillment that I had not
expected now I have to mount my
staircase alone and as I go up step by
step I am turning again round and round
apparently covering little ground but
climbing upward and I hope toward the
light
one of our great forerunners here at
Union Robert McAfee Brown said we read
biography and autobiography because we
want to learn about ourselves and I hope
that many of you have come here tonight
because you want to learn from Karen's
experience more about your own spiritual
journey so Karen Armstrong the spiral
staircase my climb out of darkness
Thank You Dean it's a great privilege to
be here in this great an important
seminary and a great privilege I I'm so
grateful to that for this warm welcome I
entered my convent when I was 17 years
old and I was so excited I really felt
that I was going to start a wonderful
new spiritual quest that I was going to
find God I was going to lose myself or
lose all the adolescent confusion and
muddle and become almost instantly of
course wise serene Buddha like inspired
and inspiring perhaps even a saint well
that didn't happen and I left about
seven years later in 1969 obscurely
broken and damaged and these dark years
aware that this biography begins
I hadn't find God in in this convent and
this was not anybody's fault
I'd been far too young to embark on such
a life that demands tremendous maturity
and I was not the right kind of person
for that kind of life I called my first
book through the narrow gate because
Jesus goes on to say only a few people
find the narrow gate and I was not one
of those for you I did meet nuns in my
religious order who were mature whole
kind compassionate people but I knew
that I wasn't going to be like that and
so with great sorrow sorrow and sadness
I left and they were everybody was in
immensely kind to me when I left that
would was hard because in a sense it
would have been so much easier to have
flounced out in a state of righteous
indignation but we were all saw
and I came out to a strange world now
why hadn't I found God well for one
thing I had found it in the convent to
my huge disappointment and secret shame
almost impossible to pray every single
morning I went into that convent Chapel
to make a meditation we practiced the a
discipline of meditation taught by Sint
Ignatius Loyola in his Spiritual
Exercises
and all I can say it was it was not for
me I have no problem concentrating
normally I can sit in front of a book
for hours at a time and not even notice
the minutes passing but when I could not
keep my mind on God for more than two
minutes immediately it either went
skittering off down a series of by
self-indulgent byways fantasies
distractions or else sunk in a sort of
torpor of gloom boredom or even sleep I
was an adolescent and didn't like
getting up so early in the morning and
this and it walked throughout the day
too we had periods of mental prayer and
the heavens remain closed now I don't
know what I thought should be happening
I certainly didn't expect visions or
voices or anything of that sort but I
felt I should have some kind of
encounter and at least I should be able
to keep my mind on God but nothing like
that after I seemed almost allergic
antipathetic to God and I would say to
my superiors look I I'm just failing at
this I cannot do it and they replied o
nonsense sister you know this is you're
exaggerating as usual everybody has an
off day but I'd love as I say to have
had an off day because that would have
meant that some of my days were on now
you can appreciate that this inability
to pray was to put it mildly something
of a draw
back for a nun and but I carried around
this as a secret cause of shame it
touched everything because a nuns
commitment must be measured by the
quality of her prayer and I began to
wonder you know whether there actually
was a God maybe it was like the
emperor's new clothes maybe none of us
could keep our minds on our prayers
maybe none of us encountered the divine
but we're all nobody it was everybody
was too afraid to say so and I found
myself wondering perhaps there isn't a
god how do we know that that God existed
or that Jesus was divine how do we know
all this and then I think well how can
God possibly reveal himself to a nun who
harbors these shameful doubts and so on
I went and when I finally left the
religious life I I struggled on in the
Catholic Church for a while and the
Dominicans kept me in longer than I
might have been when I was while I was
at Oxford University but then when I got
to London I just gave it all up without
any great fanfare
I just felt simply exhausted by religion
and for about 13 14 years I wanted
nothing to do with it and thought I'd
finished with God but I come out to a
very strange world because I had in my
period inside as it were coincided
almost exactly with the immense social
and cultural revolution of the 1960s and
we were completely isolated from any of
this when I came out in 1969 I never
heard of Vietnam I'd never heard of
President Nixon they did tell us shortly
after I entered about the Cuban Missile
Crisis because they felt they should
because the world was about to explode
in a nuclear
or um they told us to pray but they had
forgot to tell us that the crisis was
over so for about three weeks more we
scanned the clock the horizon for
mushroom clouds looking and searching
for you know and eventually one of us
plucked up the courage against all the
rules to ask what had happened about
Cuba and they said no Lord we forgot to
tell you that it's it's all out so you
can see how isolated I was and then I
confront this world of the 1960's
utterly transformed before I entered
young people had been miniature copies
of their parents wearing neat sedate
clothes polite a submissive respectful
by-and-large or at least allowed
themselves to be bossed and ordered
around no longer and young people were
where a girls wearing skirts up to their
thighs long flowing hair on the men and
above all they were confident and they
were protesting they didn't they were
always protesting about something about
the establishment the system the tyranny
of the Oxford Dongs and I thought to
myself heavens they should try the
convent if they do these kids don't know
what tyranny was the mild lace a fair
sort of spirit of my cock's Oxford
College seemed paradise to me but then I
remembered my last year in the convent
when I had been the one protesting
against a system that I believed I had
outgrown its day I was one of the last
people to go through the old system that
was reformed by the VAT Second Vatican
Council and a lot of customs had been
had congealed over the years and what
they were trying to turn us into
Victorian ladies who kept their eyes
down kept their voice quiet and never
raised never ran upstairs and and above
all were utterly submissive and here I
know
here in this Great Hall of learn of
religious learning I want to stress how
important it is to allow young people to
be able to think to express their doubts
and not to tell themselves that black is
white and white is black there was one
very revealing moment that happened just
a few weeks after I entered when I just
turned 18 and I was being put in for a
little lady like Theo theological
diploma for specially crafted for nuns
with a lot of the challenging stuff left
out which started with apologetics the
rational grounds for belief and I was
said an essay entitled assess the
historical evidence for the resurrection
well I knew what I had to do the
textbooks were there that I was told
exactly what pages to read and I
produced an essay showing that the
historicity of the resurrection was
about as unproblematic as the Battle of
Waterloo but with a sort of sinking
feeling that I really couldn't go along
with all this I just didn't see it
working out so the very nice nun who was
teaching us looked gave my essay back
and said this is very good sister you
know you'll do well in the exam and I
said but mother it isn't true is it and
she looked at me and gave a kind of moan
and inserted our hand under our tight
headrests rubbed her forehead and sighed
and said no sister it isn't true
but don't tell the others
so um now this was cut this was part of
a program we were told that at first we
were turning our back on worldly ways
and worldly ways of thinking
we had to adopt God's ways of thought
which were very different and accept
fairly the our superiors in the place of
God when we spoke to our superiors we
knelt down to remind ourselves that they
were God's representatives not just an
ordinary human being and we were told
that at the beginning we would be in
some of the the things we had to do
would seem ridiculous to us but that was
because we were still imbued with the
world and as we gain spiritual maturity
we would find sense in all this now I
can see a certain value to this you know
I think it's important to realize for
especially when you're young that you
don't know much and that you've got to
learn and that and and and to surrender
to something but if you make a habit of
pussyfooting around difficult articles
of faith and telling yourself that white
was black and black was white you can
damage your mind for one example I was
once by told by my pastina mistress to
practice machining at a machine that
didn't have a needle and this admittedly
this was the result of a
misunderstanding she thought I'd
answered her back and said there's no
needle in that machine and she said
you'll sit there and do it but then
rather like the Cuba crisis she forgot
to tell me that I could stop doing this
and for two weeks I've troubled on and
telling myself this is the point that
the this was the best way I could be
spending my time this was God's Way this
was God's Way and it may seem ridiculous
and pointless to a me a worldly secular
person but this was not the way that God
saw things now this is
I found that once I had left the
religious life and was embarking
seriously on my study at Oxford my mind
didn't work anymore as it had it it had
got out of the healthy habit of reaching
fearlessly for the truth and one day a
tutor set me a an essay saying just live
with this poem for a week write down
your personal reaction to it and I
couldn't do it
I could I could amass essays that had a
whole lot of little sort of patchwork
quilt of remarks from various literary
critics but my mind and spirit didn't
any longer leap out to meet the poem as
it had done before I'd entered the
convent and I couldn't have any ideas of
my own there was a sort of blank where
the reaction had been and it was years
before I recovered this I had in a sense
damaged my powers of thought and so it's
tremendously important I think to to say
to be clear when you don't understand
not to make not to make an idol of
opinions about the divine for example
that can only be human that can only be
man-made and and realize that they're
only professional and that if you can't
go along with a a particular theory or
discipline as the Buddha said don't do
it they used to say even my own
teachings leave them if they don't help
you
he used to liken religious doctrine to a
ruffed telling the story of a traveler
who came to a great expanse of water
desperately needed to get across but
there was no there was no bridge no
ferry so he cobbled together a raft and
paddled him
across but then the Buddha said what's
he supposed to do with the ruffed now is
he supposed to say this raft has saved
my life and have been immense historical
importance in my life so clearly I must
like load it onto my back and lug it
around with me for the rest of my days
or should he simply more it let it go
and continue his journey and the answer
is obvious and the Buddha said that's
how you should take religious teachings
monk if they don't work for you don't do
it wait listen to your inner self
now I had other difficulties I was for
about six or seven years I existed in a
state of grief leaving a convent was not
like learning to leaving a Teachers
Training College
you weren't learning a skill that left
your inner self intact
this was a conditioning that was meant
to last a lifetime and it did and
outside once I've gone outside into a
world that I've been trained to reject
at a profound level I found I simply
didn't know how to live and this was
very common I was as the head of a
massive exodus of nuns who left during
the 1970s and after a while they
realized that this was a real problem
that people were disoriented almost
needing the kind of debriefing that
people have after they've been in a cult
or something of that sort and they
needing help to sort of unthink unlearn
what they'd learnt in the convent but
there was nothing like that available
for me so I stumbled on I became
anorexic I became suicidal not because I
particularly wanted to die but I just
didn't know how to live
I'd seem to have lost the ark lost the
knack of living and I had another
problem I had undiagnosed temporal lobe
epilepsy in the convent I'd had
occasional fainting attacks where I'd
suddenly pass out for a few minutes and
I was told to pull myself together this
was sheer history
and attention-grabbing and I remember
thinking of myself
well my you know our subconscious must
be extremely slow on the uptake you'd
think by now it would have realized that
this fainting will does not attract the
sympathy and and concern that I wanted
I've been only a set of cold rebuke but
as all I went with the fainting after I
left the religious life I started
experiencing moments of absolute terror
dread it's the sort of thing that people
often have when they're dying because
their brain is in turmoil
I or I'd go out to one to a place and
find myself somewhere completely
different or I'd be outside and the
world would suddenly crack open and I
wouldn't know I wouldn't recognize my
surroundings it who everything looked
strange cinah staying - menace menacing
sinister and and and then suddenly
everything work locked back into place
well I thought I was going mad I thought
that I had rejected the world and I was
absolutely unable to live in it now it
was tearing me apart and I went to
doctors who sent in to psychiatrists and
talked about my entirely unexceptional
childhood for and nothing nothing worked
nothing touched this then came a moment
I'd reached really rock-bottom I really
you know we're talking about 1973 four
years after leaving the common no hope
eventually but the thing was diagnosed
as tepa lepsy of the temporal lobe it
comes from brain damage that I probably
received at birth there's a lesion on
the brain but that was still not
forthcoming and I thought to myself I'd
really reached the end of the road I've
tried I had been reaching out for help
I'd hope for someone to help me I mean
in a sense I wasn't really anorexic
because I know anorexia you don't get
over
I just started eating again no problem
because I realized that I wasn't gonna
get any help from outside that this this
treatment wasn't touching what ailed me
and there was going to be no help so
stop hoping to get help stay with what
you've got you've got to learn to ride
these moments out as they you're on a
roller coaster can't get off but you
know ultimately this horrible rival
comes when and just go with it it's kind
of a moment of surrender and then I went
to a lecture by Professor Dame Helen
Gardner Merton professor of English
Literature at Oxford and she was
lecturing on TS Eliot
at the poem Ash Wednesday and read aloud
to us the first poem of Ash Wednesday
which is the as it were the spine of my
book and has been of immense importance
to me on my journey
it begins if I can remember it because I
do not hope to turn again because I do
not hope because I do not hope to turn
again desiring this man's gift and that
man's scope
I no longer strive to strive towards
these things why should the age of Eagle
stretch its wings
why should I mourn the vanished power of
the usual reign and I instantly started
to sit up almost the hairs on the back
of my head raised and I felt myself the
first time in years rising spontaneously
to meet the poem feeling it going right
the way through as it has to my very
being because because it seemed to
express my own moment I had decided I
didn't hope anymore but the important
thing was not that I just given up hope
was what Elliot says halfway through he
says I renounced the Blessed face i
renounced the voice and I'd given up God
by this time who seemed an entirely
uninterested in me I renounced the
Blessed face
I renounce the voice and because I do
not hope to turn again consequently I
rejoice having to construct something
upon which to rejoice and the
awkwardness of the syntax there the
awkwardness that the phrasing reminds
you of the this is an awkward difficult
thing you're going to do but now my
project was that okay I had been dealt
this bad card I seem to be losing my
mind this was a bummer but I still had a
lot going for me after all I was still
leading extremely privileged life I was
studying at one of the best universities
in the world I had a certain amount of
intelligence and talent things could be
worse and now my project was to
construct my own joy because I do not
hope to turn again don't wait for help
to come from outside consequently I
rejoice and I would construct my own
happiness now with as much care as an
orange aeronautical expert constructs an
aeroplane or an engineer constructs a
computer with that kind of precision
this would be my life's work and things
did start to look up at that point I'd
reached absolute bottom but things on
the outward path continued to go wrong
I'd wanted to be an academic I would
wanted to teach English literature in a
university but I failed my PhD at Oxford
and I did not only fail the thing but I
failed with hideous publicity and there
was a huge scandal about it
I couldn't even seem to fail normally
and there was a five-month period when
they tried to decide what on earth to do
with me they felt there had been
irregularities in the examination
process but because they eventually
decided that because of the sanctity of
the Oxford doctorate my thesis couldn't
be reexamined so that was the end of my
academic life and then I had to go into
school teaching
then I got into school teaching I didn't
like it much for the least it was a job
and I got you know into things and I had
a little flat and all was great
but I lost my teaching job after six
years because of my bad health I by this
time the Epilepsy have been diagnose but
it took a while for the medication to
find that exactly the right kind of
medication for me and I was missing too
much school time I could see the point
they took they were good to me they they
enabled let me stay far longer than a
lot of people would have done so I left
teaching and what on earth was I going
to do now I had written my first book
through the narrow gate by this time and
then because someone saw me on TV in the
new television channel channel 4 which
was just opening up this by talking
about 1982-83 I got invited into
television so I took up for a few years
of television career I sent this to Bill
Moyers like few days ago and he said oh
we take anybody so so I started in TV
and because the this is London you have
to understand secular skeptical London
the commissioning editor for religion at
channel 4 loathed religion and wanted to
subject it to exactly the same kind of
critical scrutiny as any other
discipline one of his programs was going
to be called Jesus the evidence which is
going to start by actually blowing up a
life-size statue of Jesus at the
beginning of the program blasted to
smithereens darling he said you know
that'll show the bastards
and he kept on saying you know darling
these people are all bonkers they're all
mad darling believing this rubbish so I
was delighted to go along with this
because I'd had enough of religion
myself and I was invited to do a
six-part documentary series on some pool
and I thought to myself right this is my
chance to nails and Paul whom I'd always
regarded as responsible for much of the
ills of Christianity and I fell into the
mine of New Testament scholarship I knew
and you have to understand that I
actually knew nothing I'd done this
little little baby diploma in the
convent and it had been a useful
introduction but all my studies had been
in English literature since this time so
I was learning on the job but television
is a superficial medium and I had a
wonderful advisor to help me Michael
goda
and he was a fine New Testament scholar
and he was very tough with me very tough
with me and I I'm so grateful to him
because he taught me the importance and
rewarding nature of accuracy in
theological discussion and I found that
actually when faced with the text of
course I didn't hate some pool at all
and I of course I found out that a lot
of the work the most difficult texts
were not actually written by him and
following in his footsteps as I I was
going round the site speaking where he
had perhaps beam I found myself becoming
closely moved and and drawn to this
difficult pugnacious apostle but most
important I was making this film in
Jerusalem with an Israeli film company
it was a a peculiar no one else would
had touched this with a bargepole
because we had no money absolutely no
money there was no teleprompter and
everything had to be one take only I was
totally inexperienced in television and
at the
of the band it was and it was pretty
hard hitting about the nature of what
Christianity had become at the end of it
the Israeli director said this is a
religious program in only one respect it
is a miracle indeed it was a miracle
that we'd actually got together a
product and I found I was a even though
I'd thought I'd prove conclusively that
Paul was the first Christian that's what
we call the series the first Christian
not Jesus and that the historical roots
of Christianity were very shaky people
wrote to me and said thank you for this
now I feel I can go back to church what
hello I thought I had proved
conclusively that this there was nothing
in this that it really was bonkers ah as
John had thought but obviously I hadn't
there must have been something in that
and probably my feeling of being moved
by Paul but I was learning important
things what I was discovering the other
Abrahamic traditions and I realized in
Jerusalem how extremely parochial my
religious life had been hitherto
entirely Catholic indeed not even you
know Christian entirely Catholic and I
realized I'd never thought of Judaism as
anything except as a kind of prelude to
Christianity and I'd never thought about
Islam at all but in Jerusalem you can't
helped noticing these faiths and you
began I began to see the profound
profound connection between these
religions of Abraham and as well as the
differences between them from that
moment I started to study the other
traditions and began to find their and
also in Greek Orthodox Christianity a
whole lot of elements in the religion in
religion that had never occurred to me
before they were entirely new so it was
the study of these other faiths which
actually brought me back to a better
understanding of what my own faith had
been trying to do at its best
and they but it was a long and slow
process one of the things I learned in
Judaism was that early on I had the very
good fortune to have a conversation with
Haier Maccabee who teaches at the Leo
Beck College where I would later become
a part-time teacher and he told me told
me the story of Rabbi Hillel the elder
contemporary of Jesus who is approached
by a group of pagans who promised him
that they would convert to Judaism if he
could sum up the in pole of the Torah
while he stood on one leg and Hillel
stood on one leg and said do not do unto
others as you would not have done unto
you that is the Torah the rest is
commentary go and learn it and I said
well that's all very nice but what could
he say this was the essence of Judaism
what were these pagans supposed to
believe and I am said to me you know
easy to see you were brought up
Christian
they said in our Judaism nobody can tell
us what to do there isn't Orthodox new
theology is poetry an attempt to express
the inexpressible religion is about
doing things doing things that change
you it's not about believing Creed's
that was an entirely new idea for me I'd
struggled for years with doctrines and
believing things and struggles to
believe in and and now and this was
something I couldn't quite take in at
first but I am convinced became
convinced over the years as my studies
continued that Hillel was right that
sounds very arrogant told me but Hillel
expressed it beautifully Confucius had
uttered a version of the golden rule
himself 500 years before the Buddha had
taught it Jesus taught a version of the
golden rule this is the essence of
religion I'll come to that in a minute
in Islam
I love the pluralism of the Quran and of
some of the early Sufis I loved I loved
the fact that Sufis would cry aloud in
ecstasy that when they glimpsed the
divine they were neither Jews Christians
Muslims they were at home equally in a
synagogue a mosque
or a church because when human beings
glimpse what we call God then I his
man-made distinctions fade away and
become unimportant and all this again
was new to me entirely new and since
things were beginning to move but I was
still very skeptical in my early books
our show that skepticism and working in
television there's no time for these
truths to sink in
it's all very much quick far
hand-to-mouth and above all be to be
clever I was up there in front of the
camera and an entertaining clever guide
sniping at this debunking that with
being cheered on by the crew and
production team but then I lost my
television career which went down the
drain yes another fail I was equally
ejected from TV but there was this kind
of scandal not any of my doing but the
film I've been making on the Crusades
finished up in a lawyer's office
appending a inquiries for fraud so and I
was tarred but by this scandal so there
I was in my funny little house which is
all I could afford because like this
television didn't bring in much money in
a remote part of London and one day as I
was toiling up the street an idea seemed
to come to me out of the blue and if I
were religious in a conventional way I
would say it might have been a moment of
inspiration I thought to myself well
I've got to have a new project got to
write something though it seemed very
doubtful that I'd be able to make a
living out of writing alone but I've the
study of the Crusades has been extremely
depressing all this hatred and hostility
between the three Abrahamic religions
why not write about something that
unites them why not write explore
something that they've got in common
what about God and I decided then I'd
write my book a history of God and I
expected this book to
the somewhat skeptical debunking cast of
its predecessors I expected that I would
you show how each age refashioned God in
its own image according to its only just
manipulated the theology to suit itself
but there was a difference this time and
I it's it's a complex process and
massage just highlight two important
ingredients number one is that I was
living in silence when I'd be working in
TV we'd constantly having production
meetings chitter-chatter and was easy to
take her a text and say - you know
you're one sceptical colleagues in
secular London that look at this this is
loony and they would say bonkers darling
and that there's so but there was no one
to say that - now I was alone and
sometimes work at working alone like
this in my remote little house days
would go by sometimes when I speak only
to passing tradesmen or people in shops
and at first I very much resented this I
was full of anger and rage that these
wretched people had landed me in this
limbo and messed up my TV career and
that I was an hour out on a limb I felt
I felt I was completely out on a limb
there but gradually the silence took on
a different quality and of course
silence is a key element in the
religious in the monastic life and it's
it we practiced silence in the convent
of course but it often being full of
anxiety you know I was nearly always in
trouble about something I was worried
about something or there was a sort of
bad atmosphere I was where I was doing
needlework which I couldn't do and
was just all upset but this is a
difference there was just me nothing
between me and the text and theology I
Viki remembered what I am said theology
is a kind of poetry we should take as
much trouble with our theological
statements as if we were writing a great
poem as and our rituals should be
constructed with the same kind of care
as if we were putting on a play in
Broadway not just mindlessly chanted
either as a slogan or as a sort of glib
statement of Orthodoxy which hasn't been
thought out it should lead us as the
Greek Orthodox says to a moment of
absolute silence you know like as at the
end of a symphony when the last notes
die away and before the applause breaks
out there's that beat of silence when
you know there's nothing to be said and
I started to find my in this silence I
was having to enter into my own world
and the silence was as becoming a
musical accompaniment to the text as it
were and I was beginning to respond to
the texts in an entirely different way
they were going in and were changing
second I was lucky to find very early in
my studies when I was reading a
monumental three-volume work on it the
history of Islam are wonderful Bob
Marshall GS Hodgson's venture of Islam
there was a footnote in Volume one and
as a diligent student I always read my
footnotes and I'm very glad I did
because the Hodgson is exploit was
explaining in this chapter about
mystical esoteric Islamic thought and he
was saying Yuri the historian of
religion cannot approach this kind of
spirituality from the vantage point of
post enlightenment rationalism in a kind
of superior way look these poor yokels
didn't understand the importance of
Reason you've got to divest yourself
your preconceptions and practice what he
called the science of compassion now
what he meant by that of course key NCR
doesn't mean science in the sense of a
laboratory or physics or chemistry it's
a way of knowledge
skee NCR knowledge a knowledge based on
compassion which doesn't mean of course
feeling sorry for people but it means to
feel with and he said the historian of
religion must not leave any text any
idea any spirituality until he has come
to the point where he can imagine
himself feeling the same he has to keep
asking himself but why but why but why
and constructing in a scholarly way the
context that made this possible and and
until he feels some answering resonance
real answering resonance in his being
otherwise you'll just remain glib glib
Lisa on the on the purely rational
surface of things and so I copied this
out and I found it helpful because when
I was writing about somebody like
Muhammad for example I had even though I
didn't believe in a God myself any
longer a personal God who spoke
nevertheless I was having to enter the
mind of Muhammad a man who believed that
he had been touched by this God and
unless I could somehow I enter into that
experience see what into some degree
what it had meant to him I would miss
the essence of Muhammad now this is
important I think for two reasons a
remember the golden rule the essence of
religion I came in my studies to realize
especially with my study of the Buddha
that the religious life the essence of
the religious life is not doctrines or
beliefs it's the S
it's the practice of compassion we seek
ecstasy in our lives and ecstasy doesn't
necessarily mean going off into a trance
or a vision X star system the self to
stand outside the self and when you are
enter the mind of another you put
yourself behind and compassion is one of
the best ways as of dethroning yourself
from the center of your world and
putting another there and this I found
out over time was beginning to change me
and funnily enough and now that I was
able to relate to other people's because
I was McCann to experience a real joy
and there were moments in my study when
I would occasionally feel touched by
some form of or or wonder or delight now
my colleagues at the Leo Beck College
laugh at me and tell me that that's a
very Jewish spirituality and that this
is what Jews do when they study Torah
and Talmud this Merce themselves in the
text feel touched within and lifted
momentarily beyond themselves and son
Benedict used to make his monks practice
a discipline that he called lexie Oh
Davina divine study whereby you read
that your texts your scripture your
father's of the church and in the course
of it you might experience many seconds
of what Benedict called or @co or prayer
and this was it the kind I realized my
work was becoming a kind of meditation
the kind of meditation that I've been
able unable to do in the convent but
this was what what had happened I'm just
checking up on the time yet so I'm now
going to draw my remarks to an end I
called my book the spiral staircase
because for a number of reasons first
because that poem Ash Wednesday has been
so important in my journey
it this in all and it depicts in some of
its poems the poet climbing a spiral
staircase and even the verse twists
around upon itself like a spiral
staircase repeating the same phrases a
pack apparently going round in circles
apparently making little progress but
nevertheless advancing steadily from one
insight to another and in most missile
mythological systems a staircase like a
ladder is often a symbol of a change of
consciousness and I would now describe
myself a religious person I used to call
myself a freelance mana theist because I
drew nourishment from all three of the
monotheistic religions and could see
none of them as superior to the others
I was nourished by all three and but now
that's not really accurate because not
only have I written about the Buddha are
now engaged in the study of the Hindu
tradition and think I'm the Chinese who
have one little insights and they are
not theists in our sense so but yes I'm
a really I'm a religious person you
could even say that I'm a convalescent
as it were I'm I'm in recovery and study
is my kind of therapy bringing me back
to a sense of religion and the sacred
and living and being taught the
disciplines of ecstasy and compassion in
my study I love my work I cannot wait to
get up in the morning I am wandering
round and I have to do boring things
like drying my hair and I keep sneaking
up to the study and having a little peek
as to see what what I'm going to be
reading that day I and I just love it I
feel so privileged but I also sometimes
smile to myself because in a sense what
am i I mean I might still
none after all these years I'm never
married I live alone in silence for most
of the time when I'm not on tour ah I'm
spending my days writing thinking
speaking about God religion and
spirituality and rosemary read out that
last conclude my last conclusions where
I seem to keep on thinking of Elliot
spiral staircase and much of my life has
been so rep repetitive I kept making
stupid mistakes people kept telling me
you're not really suited for the
academic life and I wasn't it's not
really and thank goodness I did fail
that thesis I wouldn't be here tonight I
wouldn't have had been on the same
journey sometimes it's not a bad thing
to fail it just nudges you into a
different mode into a different
perception but I keep making the same
mistakes the same disasters round and
round and round yet all the time I was
changing and so here I am in front of
you a a seeker a nun on the spiral
staircase reaching out with my readers
towards the light thank you very much
thank you so much Karen for sharing your
spiritual quest with us and for helping
us to I hope come to greater discernment
of our own spiritual questions thank you
we want to give a little bit of time now
for you to ask questions or make any
comments that you might like to and
Karen asked me to feel those we have
this problem in this room about hearing
and so we do need to ask you if you have
a question to please come forward and
speak from this microphone here in the
in the middle or certainly you're
welcome to come here too but please come
to a microphone and ask your question or
make your comment and we'll take a
little while to like Karen respond
directly to you so don't be bashful
that's thank you
you just mentioned you just mentioned in
your concluding statement that you're
going towards the light could you
comment on what that light is I I
suddenly can't define it because one of
the things I've learned is that the what
is holy and what is sacred is our
indefinable that was one of the things I
learned when I was talking of
researching my book about God that all
the great traditions insist that you
cannot define God or say exactly what it
is I'm not you know I'm not so concerned
about the end I'm not concerned about
you know what happens at the end when I
get to the top of the spiral staircase
the journey I get glimpses of this light
in my study or when I Imps the holiness
of the world
there was one foot but this this I
believe this world is what we have but
what we've got to do is learn to see the
holiness that is there and that is in
every every one of us and is in our
environment
there's a wonderful passage in the
Upanishads whereby a young man who comes
back from his training as a Brahmin full
of himself and his father wants to teach
him a lesson about Brahman got what we
call the ultimate reality or God and he
fills a beaker full of with with a lump
of salt and in the morning the salt has
dissolved and he sips it at the chaplets
as a son and finds that salt has
pervaded the beaker even though he can't
see it and he says this is this is
Brahman you can't see it but it's there
and it's it's in you Special K - it's a
very important moment and we've our job
is to learn to look for the light of
holiness in the unpromising surroundings
that we have learnt us and and I think
you can only do that by the discipline
of compassion leaving yourself a slide
and opening yourself to the other Hindus
have a practice of bowing when they
encounter one another because they're
meeting that they're countering the
worshipping the divinity that they're
that they're meeting in that other human
being and I think I've finished
you know just quickly the light I don't
see it as God saying hi you know at the
end I die it's not it's oh but I hope I
suppose enlightenment is what I'd like
I'd like the Buddha is one of my
favorite people and he would say it's
not important to know what happens at
the end but you will be you'll get a
piece I suppose what I'm talking about
is the realm of sacred peace at the
center of yourself so that you can live
in the pain of this world at somehow at
peace and still and quiet that's what
I'm hoping for that's enlightenment I'm
a long way off I get glimpses of that I
get glimpses of it in other people but
and in the right wonderful writings that
I'm studying but I'm not yet met that
like and of course if I knew what it was
that wouldn't be a light the light at
all because it would be just a bright
idea of
yes thank you for a great talk of very
fresh and insightful and generous I want
to ask you a question because this may
be the only opportunity after everyone's
gonna want to talk to you about
something have you read a book that made
a great impression on me and perhaps you
haven't read it it was written by an ex
Jesuit named Jack miles called God a
biography yes I did read it
but I don't it was more of an exercise
in literary criticism I think and I
enjoyed it I thought I thought it was
brilliantly clever and and and and Jack
and I are in contact with one another
and sharing our insight and that's one
way to do it for me the the literary
approach it's not for me because it
smacks too much of my English background
and I still approach English literature
as a slightly competitive scholar I sort
of felt that fell into that habit but
it's a great book and very
thought-provoking thank you hi thank you
you said at the end of your talk you
spoke about your experience with the
three major monotheistic religions and
how as you say I think you said none
find none superior to the other and now
you've gone on to other religions I just
finished a film called hiding and
seeking which is about an Orthodox
Jewish man who is troubled by his sons
who are very religious deeply Orthodox
Jews studying in Jerusalem and their
inability to see the broader world and
the father it says what you say but at
the same time struggles with that
dilemma that it seems as if we live in a
world where people mostly many people
who are deeply religious appreciate
their own religion very much but don't
don't find the wisdom you do in other
religions and I'm just wondering if you
think it's possible for religious people
to reconcile
other other traditions as deeply as you
have I think it's essential now you see
I don't think interfaith since September
the 11th changed our world thank you
it's a very good and important question
since September the 11th changed our
world I I think this kind of
appreciation and learning isn't just a
luxury or a nice thing to do it's
essential for our survival
but the problem is great now I don't
recommend everybody to follow my
freelance monotheists or whatever it is
path that's I've had a rather peculiar
religious journey and as I say I'm
convalescing I've no idea where I'll end
up who knows I mean sight was sane us
the distinguished Islamic scholar it's
often saying to me miss Armstrong it's
time you settled down and stopped all
this sort of cruising around the the
religions and he may have a point but
for me at the moment I'm on this quest
but I think if the important thing is to
root yourself if you can in your own
tradition explore its riches to the full
stick with it go with it but learn to
look out at other people and you know in
a sense that is happening in a way it's
been happening in a way for a long time
because we do live in a plural world
whether we like it or not reliving
cheek-by-jowl with people of other
faiths and for example more Christians
read Martin Buber than Jews and Jews
read Paul Tillich and Harvey Cox Jesuits
are learning meditation from Buddhist
monks people according themselves Jewish
Buddhists or Christian Buddhists and
they are people are beginning to reach
out and reading about reaching out quite
spontaneously without any great fanfare
to other faiths and picking up the Sufi
Rumi for example very popular in the
Western quite rightly - a wonderful
mystic and poet so I think that is
happening but we
we are living in a frightening world
we're living in a global village I am
excited by the opportunities of
pluralism the discovery in the 20th
century of the faith that lies at the
root of the other traditions is has
revolutionized our world view so we can
never look at either our own faith or
other people's faith in the same way
again and I find that thrilling and
you've seen for me this study of other
religions redeemed mapme religiously it
as it were saved me but other people
find this very threatening and we have
to understand it's no good dragooning
people and say you've got to be tolerant
because that's a contradiction in terms
you and I I'd like I'd like those of us
who are inclined to the plural larger
view to drop the word toleration which I
find awfully grudging really as they
were putting up with people and go for
appreciation it doesn't mean that our
that we're being asked to give up our
own tradition but learn I get a few tips
from other people how have you done this
how have you avoided this pitfall what
can we learn from this mysticism he I
think in the monotheistic well we have a
huge amount to learn from the Buddha for
example in his with his emphasis on
practice and on compassion so so I would
commend that this this pluralistic study
it is happening but you but other people
are frightened and are retreating into
denominational ghettos where they're
erecting new barricades against the
other it's a it's a it's about identity
now we use religion to give ourselves a
sense of identity but identity can't
become the be all and end all of the
religious quest because otherwise if we
just get ego blown up as Hershell rabbi
joshua heschel said when we put
ourselves at the opposite pole of
Iko we're in the place where God is but
but people when people are frightened
they do retreat and we've got to realize
the fear that lies at the heart of so
much of the intransigence that we are
seeing around us today and try to a
swage that somehow I don't know how
those fears and anxieties I just want to
thank you for coming to Union my name is
Jennifer I'm a student here at Union and
it was lovely having you and I've been
reading so much about prayer lately for
my thesis and I was wondering you
started off talking about your prayer
life and I was wondering how that's come
full circle now with this book and the
other and thank you
prayer I mean I still to this day cannot
meditate to this day if you know the
thought of it makes me feel uneasy and
scared and frightened and depressed
because of those awful hours of failure
at the beginning but my prayer is my
study and I and this is a great thing I
I think to the prayer is for us I think
it helps us to use language in a
different way that helps to break down
the ego even when we're even when we're
singing or praising how often in life do
we actually wholeheartedly praise
somebody you know we are because we're
so concerned with ego and survival that
we all say things like oh tremendous of
course you say well you know and of
course and then we make a little
drawback as people used to say to me
orphans that do say to me things like
congratulations on your fabulous reviews
you put on weight recently or something
just to sort of prick that bubble or or
else there's you know or apology how
often do we say I am sorry because our
egos don't let us we say I'm really
sorry about that but on the other hand
you did say XY and said or you know it's
partly your fault too and prayer teaches
us a different way of using language
that leaves that frightened
ego protection behind so that we praise
without reserve express our sorrow
without preserve express our thanks
without reserve and that can teach us to
lay a new way of thinking and to lay
aside the clamorous little ego that
always wants to defend and inflate
itself and that ego keeps us from the
divine thank you very much for being
here
I think I'm sure you are aware that both
of the profession
professor Yulin officer where our it was
psychiatry and religion professors I
wonder if in all of your journeys and
thinking back on and you were obviously
a very religious young woman some of
your expectations might have been
unrealistic but have you found looking
back over all of this any religious
meaning like a sense of the transcendent
guiding these struggles and even the
sense of madness
a sense of transcendence guiding this
yeah we're in it somehow yes I think
I've found a sense of transcendence I
wouldn't say guiding it that's not my
way but other I think if you think of
the the way people have expressed the
religious impulse in across the board in
the world religions some see experience
the divine as revelation as guidance as
something coming from outside
and that's revelation that's the chief
monotheistic mode if you like where it's
an encounter with something outside
ourselves and a lot of people feel that
and that's absolutely a-okay valid other
people like the Buddhists say it's
something you elicit within yourself
that you do that you elicit within
yourself by means of your own practice
above all not thought or or by
disciplines such as yoga etc so I and
I'm more of that persuasion I think that
but you know not that's not mean that I
am right and other people are wrong
because no one
has the last word on God that the test
is that if it leads you to ultimate to
practice compassion so I I have glimpsed
Tran little transcenders and I'm
learning slowly but my view is to look
for the transcendent in other people and
not I think if we practice the Golden
Rule day by day hour by hour moment by
moment we don't have and end with
endlessly transcend ourselves we were
endlessly look into our pain say find
out what troubles us refuse to inflict
that pain on anybody else and in that
moment you've gone beyond yourself and
that's that's my way and I've got
glimpses of that's the way human beings
are supposed to be other people will
experience this differently other people
will experience guidance psychiatry has
been difficult for me largely because of
these I won't call them Dumbo's exactly
but these psychiatrists who saw me for
three or four years without diagnosing
my epilepsy which apparently is a
textbook case and they're all doctors
you know I so and they did leave me
floundering in there for a while but I
do think however and so it's rather kind
of ruined for me and that yeah a lot of
my friends is like a therapists and I
you know right so I'm willing to keep an
open mind on all this think of William
Jane sick soul the meaning being found
in the the religious meaning being found
in in the struggle and yes sometimes in
the downright pathology yes I think
because I see yes I see I see a point I
think that we all have struggle
we all experience suffering and that can
be meaningful or we can turn it in upon
ourselves and let it corrode us the
struggle the struggle can make us turn
in and sometimes it's easy to say well
you've just got to sort of find meaning
in it when you're really down it's
impossible you're numbed you're you're
beaten down so it it is IIIi think he
calls them sick souls because there was
kind of William James because these
bursts of light sudden transcendence can
be a little suspect the Greek Orthodox
find it suspect for example in that they
see it as a slow steady incremental
change and that will involve struggle
but not in an egotistic way I I do see
mysticism that the psychotherapy can be
a modern secular form of mysticism one
by one with a guru going down into the
depths of the self to find a new
strength a new personality their huge
convergences between some of the Jewish
mystics in particular who who in the
12th century are talking about free
association and and those kind of
techniques that would later become
psychotherapeutic so I think that there
are there are all kinds of convergences
there but I am slightly leery of
studying psychology or psychiatry
because of my own bad experience with it
thank you Karen before any of you leave
the room
I want to excuse Karen and Sheila Shay
who is with her
first and go into the refectory where
they will have books that Karen can sign
for you and if we wait and let you go
out first and she'll never get out
Karen Armstrong is author of through the
narrow gate Islam and the history of God
her latest the spiral staircase is
published by Knopf an imprint of Random
House visit Random House calm / Knopf
for more information
next week on public lives Catherine
Clinton's biography of abolitionist
Harriet